so what I want to do here is have a
discussion about Wally West from the new
52 and what I'm hoping is that at the
end of this video you'll understand why
so many fans were irritated at the way
his character was depicted during the
reboot of the flash series
so wally west is actually a major source
of contention for DC Comics and fans and
the reason why is because when DC had
rebooted their entire Flash series
during new 52 which saw the return of
Barry Allen as a title character the
first question asked by fans was this
where's wally west to backtrack for a
second while wally had made his debut
with DC comics prior to crisis on
Infinite Earths with flash issue number
110 in 1959 these stories saw him acting
as a sidekick to Barry under the mantle
of Kid Flash where Barry Allen was the
main character the element of a child
sidekick brought in younger readers who
loved the idea of Wally furthermore
because Barry appeared in DC showcase
number 4 in 1959 those who originally
read his stories were older and between
the ages of 35 to 40 years old meaning
that they were likely moving on to other
opportunities as a result the fan base
of Wally was growing while the fan base
of Barry was shrinking and so when
crisis on Infinite Earths happened in
1985 bringing an end to flash vol 1
resulting in the death of Barry Allen
with Wally being elevated to the role of
the main flash DC took steps to expand
on his character and create a dichotomy
between himself and Barry
to this end flash vol 2 underwriters
Mark Waid and Mike Barron focus on not
only expanding on the flash mythos but
also developing Wally as a character
between 1990 and 1999 DC introduced a
series of stories like issue number 79 s
the once and future flash featuring the
post-crisis eobard thawne in this story
while he was confronted by professor
zoom who is obsessed with Barry even
going as far as to duplicate his powers
and make himself look like the flash
traveling into the past
he arrived post-crisis and discovered
that Barry had died leading to Wally
undertaking the mantle with a sanity
pushed to its limits he engaged Wally in
a battle during which time he forced
father to face the fact that he was
holding himself back and an effort to
keep from overshadowing the legacy of
Barry this combined with the
introduction of the Speed Force during
the five-part series terminal velocity
with issues 95 3 100 L went towards
making Wally West a more powerful
version of the flash and comparison to
Barry on top of this cartoon shows like
Justice League and Justice League
Unlimited solidified Wally as a
definitive flash during the latter half
of the 20th century and meant about the
time Barry Allen returned to the DC
landscape with 2008 final crisis and
rebirth he was returning to fans who
quite literally had the attitude of
Barry Allen isn't my flash Wally West
was a flash that I grew up with met a
jump back to the new 52 while DC was
very hush-hush about Wally and his
existence in the comics in May of 2012
Digital Spy published an interview with
flash writer and artist Frances mana
pool and Brian bucha Leto during the
interview mana poet stated that because
DC made the editorial decision to have
Barry Allen return as a title character
this series initially had to focus on
Barry himself and his role as the flash
well the first 12 issues saw this coming
to fruition by laying the foundation for
Barry to become romantically involved
with patty spivot as well as reject the
affections of iris West in November of
2012 DC launched their 0 month which saw
a series of 0 publications for various
characters which focus on how they
became the respective heroes using this
as a jumping-off platform because DC
recognized the popularity of Wally West
and the fact that his character would
have to appear somewhere along the line
even if only as a nod to the pre new 52
continuity flash issue number zero saw
the introduction of Daniel West while
his character was used by mana pool and
Bucca Leto to launch a new incarnation
of the reverse-flash with issues 20
through 24 along with a subset of
one-shots initiative 23 following their
departure from the flash series and
replacement with Robert VIN Diddy and
van Jenson the character of Daniel West
was used as a jumping-off platform to
introduce Wally and his first appearance
with issue number 30 while it remain
largely ambiguous here and that he first
showed up 20 years in the future with
very claiming that something went wrong
along the timeline and that he had
figured out what the problem was poring
over newspaper clippings of heroes who
seemed to have died the reveal of Wally
West comes with the fact that he not
only died in a car accident at some
point during the 20-year gap but he's
also biracial following this fan
reaction was one of shock what I mean
here is that for most fans even if they
didn't get a carbon copy of the Wally
West they knew from before the new 52
they weren't expecting such a large
deviation from the original character
taking to the presses in an effort to
address fan concern Venditti had stated
during an interview with Newsarama
that the reason for making Wally West
biracial was to both introduce a new
type of character who could stand on his
own and reflect the desire for DC to
appeal to newer audiences in the new 52
but to also ensure the development of
Wally West came or
in the comics while some cast this
explanation aside and argued that making
Wally West biracial was more about shock
value than creating a genuinely
intriguing character whom fans could
latch on to the fact remained the
following his appearance Venditti stayed
the course by featuring Wally West a
second time with flash annual number
three in June of 2014 coming out of the
forever evil crossover which ended in
May of 2014 and saw an evil version of
the Justice League from another reality
called the crime syndicate of America
taking over the world followed by the
defeat flash annual depicts Wally as a
young boy spray-painting and try
graffiti on the side of a building with
Barry Allen stepping in to stop him from
Barry's perspective the whole city is
recovering from the crushing rule of the
crime syndicate and while they try to
pick up the pieces Wally is attempting
to tear them down using his speed to
catch up with Wally as he ran away very
surprised to learn that while he's
actually a kid now the irritation of
fans regarding this depiction of Wally
was compounded on when the police took
him to jail after which he was picked up
by zon iris who revealed to bury that
Wally's father Rudolph had run out on
him and his mother at a young age for
fans this was almost an insult and that
not only was his version of Wally West's
nothing like the one they knew prior to
new 52 but this version seemed for all
intents and purposes to be a racial
stereotype however the role of Barry
Allen and the life of Wally was expanded
over the course of issues 31 through 34
with Wally functioning as more of a
background character while Barry's main
stories dealt with his escapades against
various villains like a relic rod in the
mash up gang
Wally was always featured in DC's
efforts to tie him in by having the two
developed somewhat of a brotherly bond
initially starting out rough around the
edges because iris exists as a close
friend of Barry during the new 52 she
had appeared to him for the purpose of
helping to guide Wally and acting as a
father figure of sorts to this end issue
number 31 saw Wally meeting Barry for
the first time following his arrest
where we learned that the reason why
Wally hates the flash is because his
mother had vanished during the events of
forever evil and the flash had locked up
his uncle in issue number 32 but to have
more of a bonding moment when Wally's
taken to a baseball game by Barry now
this is an important moment for the two
and the reason why is because for Barry
he's never really had to guide anyone to
becoming a better person and for Wally
he has a lot of issues that weren't
dealt with where while I considers a
game of baseball to be boy
provides a philosophical argument and
that to him baseball is more on the
order of life as he explains pace is the
key to success and moving too fast will
cause Wally to miss out on all of the
great things life has to offer now in
this conversation
Barry isn't really referencing Wally's
desire to grow up so fast as much as his
lifestyle
when Barry talks about moving too fast
he's referencing the idea of running
with a fast crowd which is another name
for criminals and so in effect he's
telling Wally the road he's on now would
inevitably lead him down the same path
as his uncle regarding his criminal life
and land Wally and jail furthermore the
experience between the two is good for
both of them and that Barry is able to
break through some of the barriers of
Wally has up and even if only for a few
moments share the joy of one of the
players hitting a home run now following
this issue number 33 depicted Wally
lashing out of the flash himself not
realizing that he and Barry are the same
person after operating as a lookout for
some of his friends while they shop
lifted at a local store after the
arrival of the police very whisk wally
away in an effort to give him the chance
to escape the reason for this is that as
a member of the central city's police
department but also someone who has
grown close to Wally Barry is aware that
what Wally needs is someone to stand in
with him and tell him that he matters
something that he's basically been
lacking up to this point in addition to
this if you were to be arrested a second
time it would add to the list of growing
crimes that he's committed and at some
point a judge would simply call it quits
and throw Wally in jail however in the
eyes of Wally himself the flash is
responsible for his life as it exists
now prior to forever evil while Wally
didn't have his father he at least had
his mother and we're times may have been
tough when the events of forever evil
happened and his mother went missing
while he found himself isolated and
alone as a result in his mind if the
flash were supposed to be the hero of
Central City then why didn't he save
Wally's mother and so after his outburst
the police respond to the commotion
where they realized that while he had
escaped and taken back into their
custody now issue number 34 served as an
extremely important moment for Wally and
that Barry had made arrangements for him
to speak to his uncle Daniel in an
effort to coach Wally down the right
path during the conversation between the
two the belief of Wally is that the
flash had falsely imprisoned Daniel and
that by working together the
could work to get Daniel out of jail was
also interesting is that this moment
stands in stark contrast to the story of
Barry himself whose father was truly
framed for murder and arrested however
rather than playing on Wally's desire
Daniel simply admits that he committed
the crimes that he was arrested for and
that rather than trying to free a guilty
man and blaming the flash while he
should look to the flash as a hero and
recognize Daniel for what he is a
criminal when that being said we're
going to bring this video to an end and
the reason why is because at this point
there's not much information out there
beyond this on Wally West his character
is actually still being developed his
stories are still being developed and
for the most part we're really kind of
waiting on the most current story arc to
come to an end but with that being said
I will catch you guys on peace